les portes du château de la star academy
vous rouvrir soyez le bienvenu à star
académie hier soir tf1 confirmé la
rumeur
une bande annonce exclusive afin de
recruter ses futurs académiciens tu
passes l'anonymat total à la lumière qui
mord le tout sur son passage
après la première saison qui avait
révélé jennifer
[Applaudissements]
une toute nouvelle saison va voir le
jour nour prof nouvelle directrice
nouveau plateau mais à l'animation pas
de changement ni cause devraient bien
présenter cette neuvième saison sur tf1
aujourd'hui c'est le grand soir le
retour de la star academy marque aussi
le retour de la télé d'enfermement et
les académiciens pourrait sans doute
retrouver l'emblématique château de
dammarie les lys dans quelques heures
les 16 candidats de la star academy
votants
bref vous l'avez compris l'école de
chant la plus prisée de france est de
retour alors selon vous est-ce que ça va
marcher
moi c'est une énorme erreur ça programme
10 à 20 ans avec des promesses d'il ya
vingt ans je dénicher des talents
aujourd'hui via les réseaux sociaux
faire venir des grandes stars
internationales on sait aujourd'hui
qu'elles ne viennent plus sur les
plateaux donc les prime pour moi ça fera
trois millions maximum et la vraie
menace pour eux c'est la quotidienne ils
ne savent pas quoi en faire la télé
réalité en quotidienne ça ne marche plus
il voulait la mettre sur mytf1 sur le
site de tf1 va trop cher ils ont pensé à
la mettre sur pmc ce sera peut-être sur
tf1 avec la concurrence des talk shows
c'est une catastrophe donc pour moi
c'est une très mauvaise idée et petites
infos permis à chris marquès qui était
approché pour faire partie de la mission
en coulisse certainement d'accord ou
sekouh bah moi je vais donner la chance
au produit même si pour toi il est
avariée parce que moi ya une sorte de
mélancolie et de nostalgie dans mon
rétroviseur moi j'ai la sale j'adorais
regarder ça j'adorais le côté chrysalide
qui veut un papillon j'adorais jennifer
elodie et nolwenn et donc sécurisé qui
me plaît j'aimais bien le work in
progress que les gens ils apprenent âge
pour moi c'est un mélange entre le loft
et the boys on mélange et grâce au corps
professoral je trouve que c'est
intéressant donc j'y crois ouais
effectivement c'est vieillot je sais pas
si ni quoi c'est une bonne idée parce
que ses 21 ans après mais malgré tout
j'ai envie d'y croire henri mathieu
tout a été dit si c'est à dire que la
première va marcher parce qu'on a tous
un peu de mélancolie et après ça va
s'effondrer pour tout ce qu'a dit
effectivement de l'ironie peut-être n'y
aura pas de stars on s'attend à des
signes viande et mariah carey les stars
ne se déplace plus elles viennent plus
j'adore les stars françaises mais n'aura
pas star internationale c'est ce qu'on
voudra effectivement la quotidienne
savage hunt anas les talents ya the voir
ici une nouvelle star y ait changé il ya
plus des missions que de talents
aujourd'hui en france on s'est tous les
[ __ ] et le sam et 14 c est le
contre-exemple allégeance et les gens
savent comment faire date et les rites
et aujourd'hui donc tout tout est fait
tout va être faux on va être sur un
mauvais truc de mélancolie y aura plus
les moyens qu'avant aussi parce que même
tf1 a pu autant d'argent ça va être un
naufrage après la première alors on va
voir la première de star académie ce tte
le 20 octobre en ligue 1 regardez il
était dans l'inconnu total
bonsoir soyez le bienvenu
il est exactement maintenant 53 vous
avez entendu parler ces derniers temps
de star académie aujourd'hui c'est le
grand soir
bienvenue soyez les bienvenus à star
académie que va-t-il se passer
celles qui ont envie vraiment envie
d'avoir à l'envi la vie c'est un nid ça
parce que alicia elle c'est elle qui est
vraiment la cible est l ami n'aurait
donc je l'attend pas savoir pourquoi
daniel vous c'est une toile sur la
nostalgie d'abord c'est une marque qui
reste forte et je vous avez quel âge
voilà donc évidemment j'étais déjà
elle avait 72 ans
je n'ai donc pas les 33e 2 bis
mais quand même ça reste une marque
forte et en fait moi je pense qu'au
contraire la télé-réalité c'est on en a
marre pourquoi pas ce que suggère à tous
les gens de la télé réalité c'est
peut-être pas le principe est imaginé
géraldine a prononcé le nom de m mes
quatorze imaginez s'il ya des gens comme
ça alors qu'on les voit vivre et qu'on
les prend voit progresser je suis désolé
moi ça me donne envie les gens correa
b14 n'ont plus envie d'aller se faire
filmer je demande à la douche si les
gens qui sont dans la tête fait la star
a collé son excuse moi donc donc voilà
donc moi je donne la chance produit
aussi j'ai envie d'y croire mais bon on
the voice n'est pas enfermé comme tu dis
les mecs comme ça ils ont pas envie
d'aller sous la douche et puis l'état
dit les stars internationales elles
viendront plus même les stars françaises
elles viennent pas on regarde dans les
programmes français elles viennent pas
beaucoup les stars françaises et pas
relancer la star ac de mémoire c'est là
parfois qu'il leur a aussitôt relancé
très bonne production il avait relancé
avec mathieu de landes et on a les
images non ça
c'est la même couleur que la même
histoire ça y est nous y sommes ce soir
sur nrj 12 la plus grande des écoles
deschamps fait son grand retour pour 12
semaines d'aventuré l'enfant et tous les
bienvenus la star academy nouvelle
génération c'est parti
pas mal
je me rappelle mme harel parce qu'on est
on était enfin ce que nouvelle star et
on y revient ont lancé en même temps la
nouvelle star vous avez le record des 2
d'une émission de divertissement sur la
tnt depuis bas depuis que la tnt existe
et est un million huit nouvelles million
à 2 millions de mines et noir avaient
fait il ya un million c'est un mi-8
voilà on avait fait douze fois millions
ce qui était à croire que
l'argent qu'elle allait porter le marché
mais c'est beau
c'est en 2012 et ce qu'ils ont mis
derrière c'est bien ça promet
pis encore dit
franchement ils sont alors moi je vais
vous dire un truc les mecs qu'on peut
revoir là il ya un truc qui m'inquiète
gravement si en 2008 ça faisait 5
millions navré t'imagines donc ça va
être dur ouais ça veut dire oui oui car
oui mais ça madame
monsieur mais tout est poussiéreux le
court 7 nico et
nous ont enfermés pour cheyrou nettement
dépassé tout est fini tout est fait une
petite info pourquoi ils ont tardé parce
qu'il voulait absolument comme rien n'a
marché après que ça se fasse dans le
château de dammarie les lys ouais j'ai
vendu historique qui a été vendu acheté
par un homme d'affaires et qui était en
travaux jusque là récemment il pourrait
pas leur lancer avant sinon il y pensait
il ya déjà 6 sur les mots n'est pas le
look là ils vont le faire là bas moi j'y
crois pas du tout ça ne va pas
absolument marchait je suis pas sur moi
je suis moi je pense ça peut marcher ses
rivales à combien c'est un échec à
combien c'est une réussite mais on en
trouve à moins de 5 millions c'est 1,5
en piqué le prime jamais oui jamais
moins de 5 millions oui si je pense
commence à peler ferrand ça peut les
faires numéro 5 millions après sur la
moyenne il faudrait être entre quatre et
demi et 5
4 et je les fais plus rien la mission
est ce vrai mais souvent il sait bien me
sens mais là ça ça revient c'est y avoir
il va avoir un appel d'air a lancé une
version écourtée je crois qu'ils vont
faire un mois au moins 10 et sein
d'accor est la même c'est bon le
d'hébétude mi chemin que ça fait deux
mois et demi à deux mois nuit 18 mois
comment vous êtes sur les calendriers
salaire et
18 semaines et là elle va durer que 10
semaines devrait donc deux mois et demi
oui gagnant il a quoi je l'aï là
attendez on va vous dire à ton nom juste
je pense que paradoxalement c'est la
quotidienne qui avait de mieux marché
que prime parce qu'effectivement je
pense que la six mois je pense que
justement la télé d'enfermement telle
qu'elle était filmée il ya quelques
années là je pense qu'elle peut être un
peu de nostalgie donc pas de mélancolie
matthieu delormeau en revanche le prime
time techteam ans je pense que les cris
a été fait précédemment ça ne marchera
pas ça c'est sûr voilà anissa tu connais
tu sais toi la star belge était pas
année je crois
du code napoléon n'était pas née
2011-2012 en 2012
et ben moi je préfère même catégorie en
fait que la star academy en tout cas je
ferai passer raconte yann thirion ça te
dit rien du doute va pas regarder non
mais même ça me dit rien enfin j'ai vu
les images ça me satisfait pas du tout
bon alors on va voir justement la
dernière de la secret story est bon mais
on a bien vu
dernier prime de la star ac sur tf1 peu
s'en souviennent on va voir un extrait
c'est la victoire de michael meeks
macaza michael reha en 2008 à l'époque
j'étais rihanna qu'elles vont chez le
vainqueur
à l'époque c'était
bientôt sur les rites anouk
c'est parti
veinarde decies gagnante de la star
academy numéro 8
weiner et le camion c'est un des matches
les jeunes félicitations indiqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
at et little edie week end vous donner
une idée des stars internationales nous
on avait demandé une rig et les ja il
reprenait 0 cachet mais juste pour venir
depuis los angeles avec son star ils
étaient 18 des maquilleurs nana toute en
business dormir au george 5 et tout
juste son déplacement pour venir cd
chanter sur la lune nrj 12 un soir et
tout ça coûte et 400000 euros évidemment
la chesnaie non mais c'est pour vous
dire ce que c'est ce que coûte un
déplacement de stars comme mariah carey
alors on veut avoir vous avez pris à la
pana righi
alors oui moi aussi
j'adore la main à l'époque les maisons
de disques payer ouais ouais les maisons
de disques emi merci aussi aux médias
mais là où on attendait une phrase
arrière à l'époque où toutes les maisons
de disques
à l'époque vous avec les maisons dix
pays non mais c'est vrai alors qu'était
qui a été approché qui voit là jean
pascal lagarde
c'est bien
sûr ce serait super ça donne envie moi
c'est super idéal à écouter alors il ya
bien d'autres anciens sont des coachs ah
ouais ouais nora qui
s'est passé dans l'axé man des maisons
contacter d'anciens élèves pour devenir
coachs vocaux alors on a ça c'est pas
qui va être la directrice on sait pas
s'il a lui même s'il rêve d'un profil
d'un ami cas oui j'entends mika une
personnalité très connue il faut qu'ils
m'en avoir mille cas le chocolat mais
ils opteraient pour des célébrités
plutôt que des anonymes parce qu'à
l'époque c'était des anonymes alexia
laroche joubert si c'était des nouveaux
talents qu'on découvre à l'antenne et
live accord vise les pubs sur des
personnalités et alors ça va être ça va
être dans le savez tous saluent toi
dammarie-les-lys
absolument on devrait le château
historique pourquoi ils ont joué rue
louis et le loup oui ça a été racheté en
2008 comédie
[Applaudissements]
il a
[Rires]
été relancé au canada oui
academy carnet avec lara fabian xavier
dolan avec xavier dolan en prof de
théâtre m e carton n'a pas démérité ce
récital est gentil ça les maisons des
gens aussi fort ici oui et alors et ça
cela continue il sera tout en images par
la wii tout en images pas d'animateur il
voulait mettre une co animatrice à nico
satisfait pas karine ferri ils ont parlé
et ils ne savent pas quoi faire parce
que aujourd'hui ils veulent aller
chercher des jeunes regardent et à nice
elle s'en fout complètement bien sûr un
cho qui prennent tous les jeunes les
téléréalités ils en prennent encore un
peu même si ça m'a rien sur honnêtement
si m la quotidienne sur tf1 de tmc ils
sont moi j'y crois pas on va pas du tout
il faut qu'un amateur incarna
quotidiennement george pipas pas dans le
sens de la marche au canada ça marche
avec moi en france s'est passé au canada
c'est le canada ouais ouais il est
organisé des archives dans un bon
casting avec benoît professeur je pense
que ça peut aussi font des moyens avant
j'y crois je pense simplement que chacun
ait un numéro la première après vous
pensez que ça fait deux mois et demi sur
dix ça fait donc dix semaines s'est
assis ça va mais la quotidienne et
tooway tm si jamais le léman ton cul
était et est excellent appartient plus
il la met tout pas non à mon avis je
pense jamais à mettre sur tmc à vendin
keller ouy aller avant
le match à 18h matadi vous cacher ils
vont le mettre à 18h sur tmc alors ouais
bah je pense à saucisse à ses toiles
non pas du tout l'esprit du mât les
expos n'essaie de la maison ça academy
c'est chez vous un peu
voulu berne épidémie
oui mais ça va mais
c'est dans le même
ses proches de bourhis très prochain
connu quand même oui ses proches
par les images in-game
dammarie les lys en
[Rires]
convoi pour moi le gagnant que
l'emblématique de l'émission c'est bien
sûr une allégorie de marché qui se fait
déjà quinze ans c'était la saison 4
grégory regarder
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la star academy 4 été
remporté par mme joly
[Applaudissements]
là on est dans la rue
j'attends juste debout
celui ci attendait devant des millions
[Musique]
vous pensez que ça va fonctionner
franchement oui
si vous n'étiez pas produite n'avait pas
d'adressé domaine avait arrêté arrêté
oui mais question bien sûr que ça va
marcher dans ce qui a donné envie à tf1
de faire cette émission c'est les prime
qu'ils ont fait l'année dernière sur sur
la nostalgie ça fait que 3 millions
ouvert à tous est de mauvaise augure
pour la suite ça va faire 4 millions 7
le premier prime ensuite il feint
péniblement 3 millions franchement c'est
pas le mail et bientôt la star est ça la
vraie question à poser oui tout à fait
jusqu'à quand vous allez prendre les
téléspectateurs que vous aimez vraiment
des cons voilà pourquoi c'est vous que
la star academy le marché oui jusqu'à 2
cyrille bien cyrille pendant les vidéos
les vidéos jeux mais je le dis je suis
j'espère mais avec dure voilà alors
l'objet passé j'espère que ça va être
dur maintenant ce que vous avez dit
pendant les magnétos j'ai dit ça va être
dur mais on salue tous nos s'est dit
quoi vous faire parler tu mets la main
dans lequel a pas d'accord
j'ai dit que j'y croyais pas de ouf elle
c'est déjà mieux on avance encore
c'était pas la phrase vraiment dans le
continent
tu crois pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
ça allait pas de la star ac a parlé de
tpm people
[Rires]